[Music]
the loud house first aired in 2016 and
it quickly became one of the most
popular Nickelodeon shows have you
noticed the many references this show
makes to your favorite cartoons
it looks like the Creator really loves
Sponge Bob Squarepants if you want to
watch just one more video the premium is
the platform where you should go get
early access to videos from the things
the taco the trendy the richest and many
other great channels in one place with
ad free browsing click this link to sign
up for the premium and get ready to
binge watch videos from your favorite
channels don't forget to give this video
a big thumbs up and subscribe today
we're putting on our detective hats and
checking out 10 the loud house
references to your favorite characters
SpongeBob SquarePants
let's just jump right into it although
the loud house is a new kid on the block
when it comes to cartoons it's clearly
taking over the world did you know that
the loud house is already more popular
than Sponge Bob Squarepants
even though Sponge Bob was first
released in 1999 the amount of Sponge
Bob references in the loud house is
absolutely insane and we bet you weren't
able to catch every single reference in
season 1 episode 1 you can see the loud
sister fighting over a remote but have
you ever noticed the show that was
playing in the background you can
briefly see it but some say it shows a
sponge and a starfish could it be a
reference to Sponge Bob Squarepants it
wouldn't be the only time the loud house
would use Sponge Bob in their episodes
in season 2 episode 5 4 year old Lisa
Louds kindergarten class has a picture
of what looks to be Sponge Bob
characters on a wall you think that's
all don't worry we have plenty more
references coming your way and we'll
show you even more Sponge Bob references
as we make our way through this video
did you know that there are many fans
out there begging for the loud house to
do an official spongebob crossover and
create episodes with spongebob and the
rest of the characters wouldn't that be
just awesome The Fairly OddParents
speaking of favorite cartoon shows
crossing over the loud house fans have
also made several mashups with The
Fairly OddParents which has been around
since 2001 we think timmy turner and the
loud family would get along perfectly
but we also have proof that some
references for the
Fairly OddParents made it to the loud
house it wasn't just references it was
the entire show loud houses episode 8 of
the second season featured a crossover
with all original characters from The
Fairly OddParents
in the episode Lisa loud builds a portal
in her room that lets her travel from
dimmsdale to royal woods as dimmsdale as
the city where the characters of The
Fairly OddParents live you can figure
out what happened next
Timmy finds a strange portal in the
garage and enters the world of the loud
family
it's the collab many have waited for and
we loved this episode even the theme
song for this episode features a mix of
the jazz theme from The Fairly
OddParents and the punk rock theme from
the loud house
it's no wonder fans are asking for a
similar crossover with characters from
Sponge Bob make it happen Nickelodeon we
hope that the series will feature even
more cartoon crossovers as it continues
which cartoon would you like to see in
the loud house
hey Arnold here's a question for the
biggest the loud house fans out there
have you seen the loud house episode
with a hey Arnold's reference we
promised we're not making this up it's
totally there in the 15th episode of the
first season
Lincoln loud is at the community
swimming pool where we can spot many
seniors but if you look closely you'll
notice that those seniors look strangely
familiar check out this scene it's not
just Arnold's grandpa Phil from hey
Arnold
you can also spot the grumpy miss
bitters from invader zim and Jimmy
neutrons teacher miss fowl from The
Adventures of Jimmy Neutron even Iroh
from Avatar The Last Airbender appeared
in that community swimming pool imagine
you could go swimming like Lincoln did
and ran into your favorite cartoon
characters but out of all these
references our favorite has to be
Arnold's grandpa Phil from hey Arnold
we wish the creator's would consider
showing more characters from the popular
cartoon having a complete crossover
episode between the two worlds would
definitely be an interesting experience
why were these characters there in the
first place we have no idea but we hope
this means they'll make another secret
appearance in future episodes more
Sponge Bob even though the loud house
beat Sponge Bob Squarepants on the
popular Nickelodeon charts the creator
of the show Chris Savino mentioned that
there are no feuds between the two shows
in fact he claims they're all one family
and is incredibly honored to be standing
along such an iconic cartoon perhaps
this is why you can find so many
SpongeBob SquarePants references in the
loud house
or perhaps Chris feels guilty his
brand-new show is beating the popular
cartoon that celebrated its 18th
anniversary
here's another subtle spongebob
reference Chris managed to put into his
show in the 12th episode of the first
season
Lincoln is seen dumping the trash but
have you noticed the star-shaped
character on the trash it looks
suspiciously like patrick Star while
this reference hasn't been confirmed the
shape of that star does look like the
popular SpongeBob SquarePants character
we're not sure why Lincoln is in lola's
room in the first place
but we do wonder if her room has any
other furniture featuring references to
our favorite cartoons we'll keep an eye
on her room in future episodes we're not
done with Sponge Bob just yet there's a
lot more to come why do you think Chris
Tavano decided to give the popular
sponge so many tributes big hero 6
we've seen some cartoon references in
Lola's room but have you ever paid any
attention to Lincoln's room we can't
blame you if you haven't because his
room is about the size of a closet and
although his room can barely fit in a
bed and a wardrobe the creator decided
to also put in some characters as a
reference to cartoons and movies doesn't
this guy look just like the big hero 6
character could it be a coincidence his
wardrobe also features a green
three-headed dragon that could very well
be a reference to an old Japanese movie
called three-headed monster we bet you
can probably find many more references
if you pay close attention to the kids
rooms the creator of the show mentioned
that his inspiration behind the loud
house comes from living with nine
siblings and some of them had the same
names as the characters from the loud
family he also said his inspiration
comes from Sunday comics he enjoyed as a
child maybe this is the reason why we
can spot so many references in this show
from cartoons and movies as well as
songs the loud house is packed with
references and we're not done with our
list just yet
Futurama so far we've shown you quite an
extensive reference this show has had
the Spongebob Squarepants it even made a
few quick and very subtle tributes to
some minor characters from your favorite
cartoons like hey Arnold
it had an entire episode crossover with
The Fairly OddParents but that's not all
of it the show also featured several
scenes and dialogue that were influenced
by Futurama in season 2 episode 16 we
get to see the loud family enjoy a prank
free April Fool's date because the
prankster of the family Louann is at a
clown camp as the family debates how to
avoid the chances again
pranked the four year old Lisa mentions
they could put her in a freezing chamber
of course her family doesn't agree with
that idea but the tube Lisa builds looks
like it could very well be something
from Futurama in another episode
Lincoln references the famous take my
money Futurama meme as he hilariously
shouts at a delivery drone and throws
cash at it we totally feel you on that
one Lincoln delivery drones are awesome
but that's not the end of Futurama
references in an episode called come
sail away the loud family hosts an
annual garage sale and Lincoln wants to
sell a toy rocket that features the same
colors as the Planet Express ship from
Futurama could this be a coincidence or
is it a reference to the awesome show
that ended in 2013 Dexter's Laboratory
are you a fan of Dexter's Laboratory
here's something that's going to make
you feel really old Dexter's Laboratory
was first released in 1996 which means
the show is probably older than some of
you guys season 1 episode 23 of the loud
house seems to share the same script you
can find in season 3 episode 11 of
Dexter's Laboratory let's check it out
in one of the boys Lincoln gets tired of
living with ten sisters we can't blame
you buddy so he wishes he could have 10
brothers instead Lisa of course made a
portal that could transport Lincoln to
live in the world of his dreams
the next day Lincoln wakes up and
realizes that his 10 dream brothers
aren't as overprotective and clean as
his sisters in Dexter's Laboratory
episode called
oh brother Dexter gets tired of DeeDee
wrecking stop so he changes her gender
the next morning his mom calls him for
breakfast along with his brother the
male version of DeeDee is only
interested in sports and gives Dexter a
much harder time than the girl DeeDee
ever did could it be that the two shows
shared a recycled script or is this just
a coincidence we think this is a subtle
reference to Dexter's Laboratory that
was only caught by the biggest fans of
the show
control-alt-delete although it's not a
cartoon a reference to the
control-alt-delete also managed to make
its way into a couple of the loud house
episodes you can catch it every time you
see Luann's room luan is the goofiest
out of all the loud family children and
she's also known as the biggest
prankster her field jokes and terrible
puns are our absolute favorite she loves
to make people laugh but from what it
seems like she also loves the web comic
called control-alt-delete which you can
find on her rooms
wall it's a stick-figure version of the
infamous lost comic Chris Savino the
creator of the show previously mentioned
he always wanted to make a comic strip
and he used to love reading the Sunday
comics well he never mentioned he's a
fan of control-alt-delete we can assume
that this reference is Chris's shout-out
to his dream of creating a comic strip
we can't wait to see all the references
it'll include did you know that the loud
house originally started as a part of
the Nickelodeon animated shorts program
one of Chris's pitch ideas for the
program was a big family idea of white
rabbits as much as Chris wanted to do an
animal based show it was later suggested
he changed the rabbits to humans instead
we're so glad he did peanuts
speaking of modeling the show after an
already established cartoon the loud
house with influenced by peanuts as well
as Charlie Brown if you remember peanuts
you know that these cartoons are paced
slower than the shows you see today as
kids need more comical stimulation and
they need it fast
Chris combines peanuts with very strong
and comical characters and made it work
in season 1 episode 14 Lana has to take
her sister's place in a Miss prim and
perfect pageant the title itself is a
reference to the controversial toddlers
and tiaras but have you ever noticed a
peanuts reference in the episode when
Lana gets told the prize for the pageant
you can see some angels floating by and
one of them looks a lot like Charlie
Brown can you imagine a crossover
between the loud house and peanuts it
would possibly be one of the greatest
episodes ever sure the graphics would
have to be adjusted but we're pretty
sure the characters would cause amazing
havoc still the best crossover the lab
house could make is with the show that
has been referenced more than any other
cartoons we've mentioned we've seen this
character on the trash in Lola's room
and on the TV while the girls were
fighting for the remote these are very
subtle but we think the show is hiding
one more reference even more Sponge Bob
of course we're talking about Sponge Bob
Squarepants we're really starting to
think that this is the creator's tribute
and an apology for knocking down an old
fan favorite show from Nickelodeon's top
cartoon list in the fourth episode of
season one Lincoln is seen taking a bus
have you ever noticed the magazine
Lincoln was reading it says giant sub
but the colors of the submarine and the
background look very similar to the
color scheme of Spongebob Squarepants
while spongebob doesn't feature a
submarine of this shape
know that sandy has a red submarine
we've also previously seen the orange
submarine looking bikini bottom bus is
it just a coincidence that Lincoln is
reading a submarine related magazine
instead of going for his typical science
fiction and videogame literature I guess
we'll never really find out we bet this
show has many more references than the
ones we've shown you today if you watch
the loud house and know of more
references please comment below to let
us know
speaking of references can you name the
artist and the title of every single
song loon aloud saying on the show we
could make a whole nother video just on
her song references and that's it for
the loud house references to your
favorite cartoons don't forget to hit
that like button and subscribe for more
videos like this one check out 10 subtle
jokes in popular kids shows only adults
will get
[Music]